we focus on the idea of happiness too
much and the problem with that is is
that it takes our focus away from aims
that would be more productive it's much
better to aim for meaning than for
happiness 12 rules for lies about how to
live properly in the face of
vulnerability tragedy and malevolence
one of the propositions in 12 rules for
life is that life existence is usefully
characterized as an interplay of order
and chaos or unknown and known you are
always striving to balance those two if
if what you what you're doing is too
familiar you're bored and if what you're
doing is too unfamiliar then you're
anxious and what you want to do is find
the harmonious line between those two
and that's signified by meaning if you
can get those two things right then you
can have your cake and eat it too I hope
people can take away the idea that there
is a mode of being in the face of the
vulnerability and tragedy of life that
is noble and powerful and capable of
sustaining them through the worst
possible times without becoming corrupt
and bitter
[Music]